okay so I recently started reading Full
Metal Alchemist completely blind for my
very first time on my YouTube channel
and let me tell you Fullmetal Alchemist
is freaking sneaky dude oh let's do
light-hearted adventure for the first
four chapters and then boom
[Music]
I really didn't know anything about this
series other than that people loved it
so when I was four chapters in I was
sitting there thinking oh this is nice a
fun little manga about these two Misfit
boys and their lightheaded adventures in
this wonderful realized world so when I
tell you that this took me by
surprise and shook me to my very core I
mean it what is wrong with this woman
this woman who thinks she's a cow and
thinks it's cool to toy with people's
emotions like this